here with more Fox News contributor
Lawrence Jones Lawrence I got a lot of
reaction that was a heartbreaking
interview last night I thought about it
all night and all day today please if
you talk to that family again please
send our prayers and our love and our
support I don't know how you recover
from that yeah brother it was a tough
interview good evening Sean thank you so
much for having me yesterday when we
brought to you that heartbreaking
interview the the shootings had
increased to a hundred and thirty
percent based on the information I'm
getting from my sources in the police
department the shootings have now
increased to one hundred and sixty one
percent and last night with a bloodbath
18 people were shot a 17 year old is now
dead I went to East Harlem to talk to
the residents to get their voice and
here's what they had to say watch know
that's why I walk around with a baby on
me that's why I got my license no the
police it's a blame show you know
everybody it's like oh you know it's
like do you think it was the bad move to
take those cops I feel bad cause you
know it's they killing innocent people
kids do you feel safe in the community
they cut a billion dollars from the
police and it looks like crime to stick
going up right now do you feel like
that's the solution
I think what's happening right now is
the people are policing themselves Shawn
and is not just a residents of New York
that are saying is the PPA president Pat
Lynch says that the blame lies with Bill
de Blasio the mayor of New York he lives
in this house right behind me he says it
was the response to cutting 1 billion
dollars as well as getting rid of the
anti-crime unit take a look at what he
had to say Pat 18 people were shot last
night why because the city has given our
streets back when I say the city our
city council our mayor's office in the
state legislature have handcuffed police
officers and given the streets back to
the criminal remember just a few short
years ago the city was out of control
police officers literally took our
street corners back block by block
because our leadership asked us to and
we presented these neighborhoods back to
the good hard-working people that were
in them well this administration decided
that's not good they demonize police
officers they've changed the rules where
it's impossible to do our job and the
criminals take advantage of that when a
criminal hears from City Hall there's
gonna be a soft touch on crime they know
exactly what that means it means there's
a smorgasbord on the street and we're
gonna take advantage of it and they have
where we have children being shot on the
streets how terrible can that be a
one-year-old was killed
a one-year-old on top of a 14 year old a
15 year old our aspiring basketball
player in the Bronx who was going to
announce to his mother what college he
chose to go to but before he can do that
was gunned down it's happening so often
now we're forgetting the tragedy that
happened
before that we're waking up in the
morning and say how many last night
that's crazy
is the mayor responsible tell me about
him cutting 1 billion dollars from the
police department and the impact that's
gonna have on the police department well
it's not just one thing but saying we're
going to take 1 billion dollars from
your budget because there was a slogan
on a sign at a March and
and the mayor says we're gonna do that
the fund the police defund the police
now I love it as a person that have
protested in my life with protests for
fairness for police officers that I've
even marched I'd like it because you say
defund the police the definition can
mean something to you and something
different to me so they start yelling it
then you have the cowardice of our city
council and and and the mayor's office
trying to figure out what the protest is
one mm-hmm they're not gonna stop at a
billion dollars they don't want police
officers on our streets they don't want
us take in the guns out of perps belts
they don't want us keeping our children
safe in school but what's next what
what's the next slogan we're going to
chase is there any hope of taking the
city back you know what I'm a guy that
always sees a path I'm a guy that always
sees the light at the end of the tunnel
but I'll be honest with you I'm having a
hard time even seeing the tunnel now
Sean
he also said an interview that he's all
for getting rid of all the bad apples
that are in the police department
he doesn't want him a part of the police
department but the way that the mayor is
handling this is gonna get people killed
back to you soon
all right Lawrence thanks for that
report